gang ticks are going quick for that
state trashy tour hachimachi do yourself
a favor don't be left out in the cold
scoop up some ticks yep gang are you
garbage.com all tickets are available
for our shows coming up and baby is
there a lot of them we got Phoenix
Denver Salt Lake City Los Angeles San
Diego Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Toronto Pontiac Michigan uh Chicago
Minneapolis Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee
Wisconsin Sacramento San Francisco uh
San Jose and then ended it in
Philadelphia baby the boys are coming
home get those tickets we'll see you out
there see you out there welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the group to be classy yeah they're just
a big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here with
titties in the new edition she's
upstairs with the mailman okay he's
getting the gutters cleaned out all
right my co-host is coming at you right
next to me Swinging a miss this week he
is the CEO of are you garbage and he is
Mr Neptune 2004 for the summertime give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
over 150 000 over there then obviously
the greatest website of all time I'd be
remiss if I didn't mention it
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it out it's a [__] party shout
out to the army of garbage we [__]
love you gang and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours my best friend and he crosses
the t's and he dots the eyes give it up
for T-Bone mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen
everybody look at him what up dude no
I'm so stoked we gotta we got the power
couple in the Edition
running around the neighborhood every
now and again that's sweet are you guys
in Astoria yeah I'm gonna store you yeah
down by the water I'm in Washington he's
by a dock it's he really sells it as the
waterfront property we'll get into it
gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited to have two of
our absolute [__] favorites here with
this in the studio both family at this
point we got them together give it up
for saratog and Mr Joe list everybody
is it true you drugged a woman to play
with her toys toxic squirrels I feel bad
that you have Sarah and I on the same
time because I'm a hundred percent
Seinfeld references that's true you're
not a Seinfeld gal not
re I mean I'll sit down and watch and I
can enjoy I'm like that with the
Simpsons and Family Guy okay now where
I'm like Family Guy is enjoyable but if
you're coming at me with references I
don't know your language sure yeah it's
funny that you Norman me and him would
cut from the same cloth yeah there's a
few others Andy Fiore
yeah Donnelly's great yeah it's good how
often is it on at the house uh it was
awesome every morning day every morning
no that's ridiculous I watch it every
day
my thing is and maybe we we said this
before but I I've I've recorded every
Seinfeld when I was a boy like on I have
the original I have seasons seven eight
and nine original broadcast on VHS and
then all the reruns so I had like bi I
got boxes of tapes what movie I don't
know the Departed yeah oh I got barking
can't be going Seinfeld The Departed oh
that's your references and expect me to
pull a line wow that's not even a famous
line that's what he's got the gun yeah I
got boxes of tickets not say I knew Jay
Raymond Schneider I said he touched me
on the shoulder once but anyways I
watched so many when I was a kid I came
home Matt Wayne's another one by the way
how old were you when that was on the
air
um you had to be in high school yeah I
was like 8th 9th 10th grade the finals
and you were that in if you were dancing
I was obsessed yeah an old soul I'm an
old talking about Jewish guys on the
Upper East Side in their dating lives
but I was like what
yeah huh okay but anyways I still watch
it quite a bit yeah and so that like you
said before you I know most of the time
I'm watching Seinfeld Sopranos and I've
been watching The Wolf of Wall Street
over and over again it's been driving my
girlfriend [__] nuts we have a lot of
Martin Scorsese going on yeah he's good
at what he does the Irishman if that's I
just I'll throw that on I'm watching it
currently I'm watching Seinfeld the
Irishman I like the iron that is those
are just wild shows to put on cash
movies to put on casually well what was
your bit remember I was obsessed with
um what's the one uh Manchester by the
sea oh Jesus Christ I watched that like
12 times in like four days that's
[__] nuts I love a good kid burning
story yes
it's a great film
Casey Affleck does try to kill himself
that's that's good cinema right there I
love it that's all I want in my life is
to try to kill myself and someone saves
me at the last second what are you
watching gotta get out more dude I right
now I'm into reality TV Vanderpump Rules
that's all right I don't know what the
hell that is i that's been around
forever too at least nine years I
stopped watching after season two and
then because it was kind of like a guy
that looks like Zorro the guy with the
mustache Jax yeah oh no that's Tom
Sandoval so they've called it scandival
yes
his girlfriend's best friend and what
are they from is it just a restaurant it
makes me miss one of them was I just
Googled it one of them was on Real
Housewives yeah one of the Lisa
Vanderpump the main [__] as I call her
they're
my friends they're not nuns
they're all delineated from that woman
right yes okay and then you're watching
some other every time I come home now
you have something else on a period
piece
oh God you guys on yesterday the Queen's
Gambit it was literally yesterday you've
come home the last two times I came home
I saw the saved screen thing oh no
because that's the commercial for
Vanderpump Rules if you pause it on oh
peacock it shows Outlander so it makes
it look like I'm watching a period piece
oh but I'm not you guys watch anything
together yeah will you sit down and
throw something on a film we'll watch a
film yeah we um it's hard because at
night you're like well we can't get into
anything in depth with like other
languages okay so it has to be like what
do you mean like meaning like you don't
have the brands to watch at the end of
the night yeah so a lot of the times
it'll be something that we've already
seen like we just watched white man
can't jump yeah
um the new one or the old one old one
okay and then cutting Peg Joe is a Big
Jack Harlow guy
I never heard this Joe Mayo character
uh no we try to watch movies well
because it's very funny we've had both
of you in here separately a couple of
times
yeah and it's it's hard to jail yes
because it's everything like yeah I
don't need anything she cooks he doesn't
do this we don't do it baby it's very
two ships passing in the night I feel a
big gel a lot of gel this is common
though like I do I like any movie but I
feel like Joe probably won't sit down
and watch the type of TV that you want
to watch sure you're not a reality guy
no a lot of people think it's trash I do
too but I like I call it my sports it's
a little game of mental chess and it
takes 10 years to to get to the bottom
of it yes yes well I have uh mental
problems too I feel like some certain TV
feels like it like triggers like a game
show or a reality show I feel like I'm
wasting my life I'm like I gotta be
watching sports or
seinfelda but Seinfeld is I mean that's
as good as it gets yeah we watch stuff
we're doing okay okay sure no but I'm
the same way I don't my wife will watch
what I'm watching
I want to push back here because we will
agree on a film a reality show I will
not for sure nor are you watching a
hockey game I'm not watching a hockey
yeah so I don't really like watching
sports on TV no I prefer Live Events I
just find it boring it's just a [__]
Aristocrat yeah I prefer the library in
the box with food and a spread so I
don't want to make it sound like we're
like I'm what we're watching [__]
Titanic [__] like we go over a movie
I'm like I can watch that I'd watch that
so you know I don't Trading Places again
sit down yeah we decided on a movie
we'll watch a movie we go to the movies
we saw the blackening the other day yep
that was fantastic are you guys coughing
Studio people over Astoria we go quite a
good movie theater but the the movies
that we like are only in there for one
day and then they take them out like I
wanted to see suzu
okay and now I'm elf on that it's like a
Revenge kind of movie with Nazi like
going against the knots I think it's a
Norwegian guy that killed a bunch of
Nazis but all the you know the
lightening it up a little bit
yeah but I think it was okay the price
is right or something I like Manhunter
movies I think it's like Tarantino like
how does the uh the domain break up in
there say there's a hockey game on
there's a TV in the living room right
one TV one TV so I go and look at tick
tocks in the bedroom I send her to the
bedroom on your phone or on the computer
on my phone I don't think anybody's on
tick tock on their computer I don't know
it doesn't hit the same okay yeah most
you've tried it yeah I just you it's
easier to do Mindless scrolling and I
share quite a few with um friends and we
never reply back to any of the memes so
hey check this out yeah check this out
on your own time or don't if you don't
feel like it so if you're watching
something if Joe's watching a hockey
game you're in the room watching Tick
Tock yes or doing some maybe light work
but most likely Tick Tock sometimes
sometimes though Sarah work because it's
a one bedroom apartment so Sarah will
work at the kitchen table which in my
eye line the TVs here and our heart is
very open so I'll just have like the
Bruins playoff game here there wasn't
many of them this year and then Sarah's
facing me like behind the TV
and then she'll be like um it's weird
when you see like a boat that looks like
it's far away I'm like what yeah we're
out of power play I'll throw out I got a
nail biter going here lady
I'll start a sentence in the middle I'm
like
they're gonna find these Titanic guys
yeah I'm like this what like what up go
I missed you guys got his shirt off but
often I think too this happens too like
you enjoy watching Tick Tock so
sometimes it just works out it's like I
like I want to watch a movie yeah I
don't mind at all well you guys go on
your phones in in bed when you're laying
in bed together before you go to bed
will you be on your phone and him be on
his phone no he's a reader
County son of a [__]
going on right now my girlfriend we're
trying to get away from the phones she's
reading but I'm on I'm strolling through
I'll do pizza yeah yeah oh yeah but
Sarah goes to bed nine hours later than
I do we're not I do we shouldn't be
together if that's what we wanted to
have these here I want to figure out
what the hell's going on break this up
once and for all we're hoping a kid will
save himself
that always works out shout out to the
Hail Mary but uh yeah no I I go to bed
at 12 15 wake up at 8 15. Sarah goes to
bed at oh yes when Joe's out of town my
bed hours get later and later to if he's
gone for at least seven days I'm at six
in the morning what I just prefer I've
always liked night or like doing stuff
at night I sometimes start my work at
2am
jeez was what are you a [__] private
eye Sarah procrastinates everything
including going to bed she's like I'll
go to bed tomorrow
all right so you sleeping until spots I
get no I because it rolls right out I
know I got a 1250 at the lounge I can
wake up at like 10 30 or sometimes
around that time I'll do noon at the
latest getting four to six hours sleep a
night that's fine no it's not I don't
think so no you got that's unlike worse
cases
good for me as if I go to bed nine
minutes in we got there I come and wake
Sarah he's like positive influence on my
time management and I come in happy I'm
one of these morning I'm like yeah
you're doing it yeah and then at bedtime
I'm like I should take my homework baby
he nods off like this on the couch he's
like like a little baby does anybody's
fall asleep on the couch and sleep on
the couch I've never maybe like twice in
my life as I've gotten older I'm not a
fall asleep during a thing person I'm
like I need to go to bed okay or else I
will fall asleep like I'm never a guy
who who's watching the movie and you
look over I'm like
I'm like I feel extremely sleepy I need
to go to bed sure more recently I guess
anybody got a cpaper no no seatbelt not
there yet okay yeah yeah fully in this
sexy line of questions
happy
you guys ever slip on your compression
socks
I just got some though you did some
compressions there you go they're all
right you wear them when you fly yes
they're good well Sarah's blowing up
like a balloon
you're pregnant you guys are having a
goddamn baby big news I threw it in
there
and then
a team of science it was more of an
assist
scraped it up yeah Joe list on the
bounce pass
no look behind the back oh
[Laughter]
what's the baby do
October 30th congratulations thank you
you know we love you both that's right
I'm very excited yeah super excited you
would mentioned it to us the last time
you were in there when last time we were
in the old which I I forg I forgot or
didn't didn't hear and then I thought we
thought that you were due like sooner
very soon in the summer no we were still
trying at that point okay yeah yeah
we've had a few uh
yeah a couple a couple kicked off
a couple of Manchester by the Seas
Toby's making a face
Toby dump this Toby looks horrified this
is live streaming by the way
wow
sunshine and rainbows with you huh
like an old bit yeah well they do
compare it to fruit right of course
right now it's a banana we're in a
banana phase oh yeah yeah
congratulations thank you all right so
what's the all right so come October are
you guys you plan on staying in the same
apartment you're in or what's the what's
the the shift here we're moving on up to
the upstairs apartment we're going up
the floor baby
nice yeah you like your building you
like your building you like your area I
love my building we live with all Comics
our landlord's the best and I I get
tyria I'm thinking about leaving it's
the proudest accomplishment of my life
our apartment I love it okay and I got
all buddies in there we got Ron on
hershberg in there with palufo and Steve
Rogers and you like the you like the
area like can you see the kids going to
school out there no
I can't wait to get out of here sure see
what are you talking about New Jersey
[Applause]
I don't know you guys are from Philly
yeah that's close we're not going to
South Jersey
not Cherry Hill folks
the plan is to move by get a house out
in Jersey yes suburbs that's my plan
Sarah's got her own plans but she's
moving to Tucson like Jersey turns into
Texas for a moment yeah you would think
well you got your family there cheap
there I mean we went down there we were
kicking around an idea yeah you go down
there you still you get a couple drinks
and you start looking at Zillow you're
like this is pretty hard yeah well you
guys could go to Texas together like if
the if we just got this place if Sarah
me and Norman got a place in Texas let's
go oh that's all touchdowns and handjobs
but I can't leave he's my breadbank
this guy's my bread and butter I could
probably get him down there if he gets
me too straight
[Laughter]
hiding out in Houston for a couple of
years
I like it but I want to be near the
shore I'd like to be an hour from the
city a half hour 20 minutes from the
beach go to the beach walk the
boardwalks is that a possibility in
Jersey in North Jersey yeah yeah there's
beaches up there there's like short you
know short points or whatever Red Bank
was Massachusetts ever on the table no
my my
family's a little
distance
the heart grows fonder yeah of course
you have to have a nice distance from
people you hate but um
I'm joking that's a joke
that's a joke I love Massachusetts but
uh I like to be near New York and uh in
a perfect world could you cohabitate
with Sarah's family if you guys are like
in the same within a 20 minutes same
house not the same house no what are you
not not the same house no Sarah's sister
lives a few blocks away I'm closer with
Sarah's sister than she is my sister and
I move into the apartment downstairs
wait your sister lives here yeah she
lives like two blocks away what I didn't
know that yeah I barely see her she's
moving I would have made a move months
ago yeah what
huh yeah she's moving into our old place
to keep it in the family
yeah you'll have a vet yes all right so
now okay so now this is shaping up all
right first year with the baby you got
your sister downstairs yes now she's
already obviously aware that you know
that's a helping out situation I think
so
I don't know is she is she what does she
do she she is a data analyst for a a
really well-known company but I don't
want to say what no of course okay and
is she single or is she she's single but
she's in a minute she likes Bad Dudes
what's happening
oh
he said she's a size six she like CPAP
machine does she have tasteful news on
her phone I just want to know what her
lifestyle is like because I mean that's
a great thing to have a support system
especially if you don't have any other
family in the city right that's your
anchor like your closest family member
is your sister but I think she's the
kind of personality plus some eye candy
for Joe
she you have to plan quite a bit ahead
to book her gotcha so there's no like
can you take the baby
I gotta do a spot for eight people it's
very important 45 minutes away from here
but we got friends
uncle renan people yep are you gonna
take them on the road I'm game for Road
for a little bit uh-huh but I talked
about fairness you're gonna have like
one of those comedy club kids you know
what I mean pass them over bring them up
on stage
We're not gonna put our kid in Limelight
situations have a month of Baby Bjorn
yeah and I'm thinking new spin-off
podcast yeah all right yeah baby Journey
baby Journey yeah when do you guys move
into the new place September so I was
gonna be like nine months pregnant okay
and great timeline great yeah and then I
think Joe's on the road the most
yeah it's a hefty September now are you
gonna do movers you're gonna do it
yourself you got a couple of bucks now
you guys are doing all right yeah I got
I'd rather do movers I think we're at a
point we could just do movers it's weird
because it's an upstairs move but my
friend who's A very wise man uh said uh
just a heads up if you're moving across
the country if you're moving upstairs
it's the same thing same price it's the
same but move it it's just it's just
yeah
I can't sell it in your head oh it's
just upstairs I'll carry the dresser off
yeah right right and you got to go
movers yeah I guess we'll go of course
and I'm sure you got to do what are you
gonna do to the nursery
I don't know what do you do what do you
mean that's gonna be good Fellas
it's Manchester by the Sea extra Spire
painted on the uh
we do have somewhat of an underwater
Motif going on we have a whale and an
octopus painting yeah so in the house
currently so it could be a Manchester by
the Sea yeah I don't know
New England I like the underwater thing
couple of fishies fish well yeah we'll
make a little underwater bubbly thing
the scary part is it the his bedroom
shares a wall with Ronan and Ronan
watches movies with the volume at 358.
okay it's Uncle Ron on he's got he's got
something you gotta have the support
system up there it's bad I mean it's
literally guns and bombs and rock like I
almost called the cops one time Saving
Private Ryan I heard it every day he was
watching a special on full volume
it was atrocious he was meaning not the
special not the special oh okay but like
I could hear it all the way downstairs
where you're like this is insanity yeah
yeah so we're gonna have to
you know
you know we have like six seats so you
have the apartment itself takes up five
and then it would invite you know
Sarah's sister and then someone goes hey
my boyfriend's in town and so you fill
up quick but I forget that you're down
the street down the street yeah yeah me
too I really blew it uh you also when we
do like a slipper I'm laughing at his
face you didn't look over I see the
reaction yeah I assume it was an eye
roll of some sort no it was the opposite
it was a dead stick
there was no eye movement okay let's
talk about sheets shout out to sheath
talk about an OG from Jump Street first
ever Advertiser when we went on our own
shout out to him Robert Patton first
people to send us free merch we we we're
all sheathed up buddy I still am I don't
know what you're talking about gang
absolutely fantastic sheath underway
they separate your nuts from your wiener
to keep it nice and cool if you want to
and also your nuts from your leg sure
right to bury your system I throw it all
in the same pocket fits comfortably too
I'll leave them in my nightstand when I
got a room down there gang sheath
underwear absolutely amazing do yourself
a pick up a pair uh yeah and they didn't
forget about our sweaty boobed listeners
summertime can be brutal for you too
check out cheese sports bras bikini
briefs and boy shorts oh look at that
shout out to a girl and a pair of sheath
boy shorts expand uh they keep it Breezy
and trendy baby go to
sheathunderwear.com use code garbage to
get 20 off your first order plus sheets
underwear 100 money back guarantee that
she's underwear dot com promo code
garbage get sheath underwear support the
show Gang support the show support your
balls do it okay let's talk about fume
baby I'm fuming Daddio as you know
quitting bad habits can be tough sure
doing a cold turkey is even tougher you
ain't lying you know what I mean it's
hard in the body it's hard on the brain
as we know luckily fume decided to take
a look at the concept of a bad habit in
a whole new light instead of quitting
the whole habit why not keep the habit
but remove the badge sure are you with
me I'm with you you're not talking about
Pinhead yeah you following me thus fume
was born Innovative device that takes
the harmful stuff out of that nasty
hand-to-mouth habit instead of
electronics instead of vapor harmful
chemicals fume uses all natural flavored
air yeah look at that uh it's really
it's really cool they were I mean also
another OG uh supporter of ours they've
been sending us stuff for years it's
fantastic uh it's definitely a different
way to look at it different way to
attack the problem I highly suggest it
with an adjustable airflow dial and
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
you can totally customize your
experience you get to hand them out I
know to give it to you uh stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy fun
easy enjoyable and even fun sometimes
fumas served over 100 000 customers and
there are thousands of success stories
there's no real reason that can't be you
join fume in accelerating Humanities
break up from destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trifum.com to use and use code
garbage to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack today that's try fume
fum.com and use code garbage to save an
additional 10 off your order today do it
gang the links in the bio now back to
the show back to the show uh you hit us
with it we went to a giggle about it all
week in the airport we brought them here
on Friday okay we were coming back from
Columbus you were going to Columbus and
fully's like oh what are you coming or
going he's like I'm going you're the
only guys coming back on a Friday
everyone else is going out to work all
right have a good weekend
well it's so exciting we saw Schultz a
minute earlier
it's fun it is fun it's a good time if
you feel like everyone's doing stuff
you're already in the airport I mean
dude come on it's [__] fantastic
that's exciting bump it in plus the
LaGuardia is real nice these days it's
beautiful I like the Delta Lounge
[Music]
you're not I I wonder if you're the same
beef as me we like the AmEx Lounge
though right
in JFK there is the Centurion Lounge
yeah they're nice yeah it's very nice
open bar
um no I don't I like to go order the
food I like to order when I go to a
lounge like before I get on plane if I'm
like I want a burger and a beer that's
what I want so I'll I'd rather just go
pay for that whereas like you're just at
the whim of whatever shitty food it's
like a bad wedding or a communion party
it's like give me better food my big
beef with uh this is my 1100th time on
the show so everyone's well aware I'm a
pretty garbagey guy and my beef with the
Delta lounges they're trying to be
they're like you're in the lounge you
must be something but some of us are
just white trash people that travel a
lot yes so I'm like you're looking at a
[__] hot dog
let me make my own sandwich
all cheese no lettuce
it's like lunch meat there's like
drizzled it's everything's drizzled with
something yeah there's no like proper
yeah scrambled eggs and bacon like yours
you can't get what you want you get like
a parfait with a whatever and it's like
iOS I have a very shitty palette um I
want a bacon egg and cheese or something
are you one of the all-time pickiest
eaters would you say I thought so and
then like my family's worse than me
Donnelly's worse than me this Donnelly's
bad Donnelly's got it pretty bad
although he's she's trying I've I was
all I was very bad my wife forced me to
get out of my comfort zone a little bit
well I'll try most stuff but I am a very
I like these 15 things that's what I eat
yeah what's it like when you two go out
to dinner if you guys go out to dinner
will you do a nice dinner will you go to
like a nice steakhouse it's usually
Italian yeah that's our base that's our
Common Ground okay
yeah where do you go in Astoria for a
nice Italian
sex sex okay it's underneath the
Kauffman Studios
um the other one that's by Michael's
we've been there that was pretty oh
bartolinos bartolinos okay and then
there's a Greek restaurant that I like
on Broadway
yes okay is that what you said yeah Bill
Bambino's nice over there on 31st Avenue
we like that Lou christini's real good
um will you share
we take no share like never shared
anything with Sarah
because you like such different things
yeah but Willie uh a Caesar salad uh
pizza
but we'll go to a steakhouse and eat
steak see I'm like I'm picky but I'm
like I will eat broccoli asparagus
Jesus Christ I'll eat some fish you
acted like you just said caviar and
oysters I've eaten well I've eaten now
you'll try [__] how is that reindeer
a little chewy
um depends on the depends on the season
depends on the artist Jose Feliciano got
no complaints anybody yeah of course
thank you I would say Feliciano can't
walk down the street
um but anyways yeah we we go out we like
Panera Panera Bread yeah Chinese food
we'll get Chinese what's the go-to order
at a Chinese place this is at the house
I'm all General style put in a Chinese
restaurant oh
yeah I don't know these lights we have a
big Seinfeld uh follow a listenership
what do you get with a Chinese spot I
like
um the eggplant thing I know exactly I
know it's exactly what you're talking
about it's good I like veggie dumplings
I like crab rangoon of course what the
[__] doesn't me
I never had it but
I like
good very good do you like uh do you
like cream cheese not really really yeah
you like imitation crab meat no I'm not
a big crab yeah then you would hate it
that's what it is it's a combination of
imitation crab meat and cream cheese
yeah I like that I like a spicy chicken
with white rice okay shove it right in
there do you use chopsticks or the four
no I bought chocolate if you did I will
eat with six every now and then like
non-chinese food no just regular just
Chinese food I could see that yeah
scrambled eggs
well Sarah's the person you could go she
can be like a surprise me and we'll just
I'll just bring food like there's times
where Sarah's been laid or something and
I just order a meal and then she's like
great that wouldn't fly with you no not
so much she would probably know what to
get you with this chicken maybe I love a
chicken bar yeah
okay even our pizza I know when we get
pizza what slice that I go for versus
him you gotta give it to him what's that
Dynamic no bubble no bubble I won't be
caught dead
I'll send it back I'll call him I'm
gonna get back here I ordered no bubbles
and you gotta see some sauce coming out
I'm a big sauce extra sauce everything
wait how does that stop never hold
anybody who I've never heard anybody
order pizza extra sauce no you got it
I've never heard until the hills bubbles
crazy well tell them about the French
fry thing this is Sarah this blows
Sarah's mind oh yeah this was of culture
a family culture thing
Joe's family orders fries with their
pizza and I just always thought that was
like oh you can't do that someone
brought this stuff yesterday too a fat
[__] thing to do to me
Steve Rogers said the same things like I
never heard of that did your family
invent this it does not like that's
Dirtbag Irish
like the pizza is the pleasure the
guiltiness and then you get a salad to
be like I guess in our minds we think it
Pizza in a salad is nice yes I'm not
even worried about it we'll do cheese
fries but we'll do like a large pizza
and cheese fries you will there we go my
family
we're at home in Philly that's what it
is it's like we'll go to a couple of
pizzas someone will get like I'll
probably chicken parm they split that
with somebody maybe and then they'll be
the three four orders of fries wow yeah
yeah that is the foleys are we never
would cross those two handful of fries
and a pizza I have a they're on the menu
a plate with fry exactly what it's not
it's like they're on the menu for 350
[__] if who doesn't want a couple
[__] tables so you're telling me
you're growing up it's wild you're
growing up it's a Friday night the list
house hey we're getting some pizzas and
buffalo wings
yeah we're putting on TGIF little Full
House a little step by step I got a
plate full of fries and a couple slices
not a piece of green room yeah this is
what throws me off the dynamic of the
ketchup on the french fries which I
assume yes of course and that's and and
the marinara sauce on the pizza that's
right yes two they Clash to me how about
this well I have members of my first of
all we call ketchup Irish marinara sure
right and I have members of my family
that for many as children they kind of
grew out of it dipped the pizza right in
the ketchup oh yeah no that's not that
far off that's that that's happened in
my circles for sure for sure there you
go I was like my mom just came up and
we're my family's very dozen
the parents generation the kids a little
bit more but like I don't think my mom's
ever had like Indian food like we were
picking out a restaurant to go to no and
the neighbors do that and it was just
like yeah you won't my my family no you
I've eaten Indian food once in Houston
with you and then once in London
and I didn't mind it I should eat it
more yeah chicken tikka masala is a
great place in uh yeah the story that's
the general cells that's like you can't
go yeah yeah
it's chicken sauce on white rice yeah
I've had Indian food the mice yeah
parents have certainly never had Indian
yeah I don't think so they've never had
Korean food Indian food Greek food for
100 we tried to take my mom we we want
to take my niece and nephew this Korean
barbecue place uh where my mom lives and
we're like Mom come on we're gonna we're
gonna go Korean barbecue
Korean Fried Chicken forget about it
it's the best and I'm like you totally
are missing out and you would love it
love it but you would absolutely love it
weird yeah dude the Korean barbecue it's
just meat on a grill with like some
salad and stuff like that mixed around
I'm like my family's like that was fish
and chips they're like oh I would never
and I'm like it's like a it's a burger
it's not even yeah you would eat it and
not even know well chicken tender is
what it is yeah fish and chips yes
they're like oh my God man that's a
really low ceiling
they're a family from Boston they think
I'm Anthony Bourdain for eating fish and
chips they're like that's crazy I'm like
it's a chicken tender yeah knucklehead
we also love
um can't do spicy so even like just
regular black Cracked Pepper that we
always have fun with that with your mom
by the way I brought my mother to
Chipotle one time she got the mild which
is literally tomatoes us
she's like I am on fire I'm like you're
eating tomatoes it's guacamole lately
but not so I I like hot I I douse it
with hot sauce I like a spicy meatball
yeah and uh she's like this is she's
like oh it's got a cake and it's like
literally like a table Peppers whatever
you call it there's people that are like
that though and I'm like I am so
fascinated by you that you're like this
eyes are watering yeah
there's a piece of bubble gum she's on
the floor
piece of big red she's out of commission
[__] my mouth is spice it's like bear
spray a lot of you guys get along Sal
you get along with Joe's mom yeah Jazz
family yeah yeah they're fun they're fun
they're like yeah they're fun we play
games it's all games at my house
drinking and games yes there's no
there's nothing from the same cloth yeah
24 7 hanging out yeah like where my
family will do four hardcore hours and
then we rejuvenate on our own do our own
thing for another four hours and then
come back together again this is at the
house at your parents house yeah like we
go to Maine every year it's Sunrise to
sundown
it's all 38 people and if you go to like
the bathroom or whatever it's like every
like it's like a game
not taking
a big idea for a movie
check it out Fourth of July baby 32 baby
yeah home run of a flick I loved it
thank you God but yeah we're playing
cards we're playing dice we're playing
we're shooting dice with your family wow
there's a dice game yeah certain dice
games I like games with your family
cornhole there's there's no dialogue
what do you guys been up to how's things
sure okay
that's that's Sarah's family it's like
you gotta you gotta know your 1300s Joe
Rogan podcasts really you're down your
parents house they have a pool right no
but it's it's the house that you you
told the house that oh the house that I
grew up and how to pull and then we
downsized when I graduated high school
to a house that didn't have a pool but
in every we call it Villages
[Music]
um they have each Village has its own
pool a community pool yeah will you go
down there when you guys go down there
do you stay at your parents house yes we
stay yes we stay with my mom in your old
room it pretty much so yeah but it's a
new house it's not the house you grew up
in it's not the house that I grew up so
I was in several of those rooms as after
I graduated gotcha yeah because it was
at that point kind of like living on my
own in certain areas and then I would
always come back and then when I did
come back was in a different room and
will you guys do breakfast with stars
yeah hey I can't go back to your old
demons I won't do it
well you guys
do only breakfast like if you're down at
her mom's will there be like breakfast
on Saturday morning maybe a Saturday
she'll make breakfast but usually she
works so we get up a little bit well the
first thing that Joe kind of picked up
on was this sleeping over my parents
don't they don't
they yell it's gonna be good well my dad
used to be like Sarah yeah
like we're children yeah and you'd be
like this like in your 30s and he would
still do it but my mom would be like set
up breakfast is nearly breakfast is then
he just does that the whole time at our
house right now she's like a British
intellectual Sarah breakfast is nearly
ready
the best way I can sum up my hanging out
with Sarah's family is
um the J George is at dinner with Jay
Peterman and he goes what about sports
you like sports yeah that's what it
feels like we literally are talking
about like the Czechoslovakian
government
1985 economic and I'm like this
how about Jordan you ever see any Jordan
he can really fly guys you guys watch
The Last Dance what's happening I like
Mike Lupica
I have to say I can't really hang in
those conversations as well it's like
it's heavy yeah no for sure we would
play trivia Pursuit and it would just be
my dad and I with one piece for four
hours
and then my mom and my brother would
just have their whole thing because
they're very smart people a lot of
readers readers yeah and I feel like I'm
like in my family I'm pretty in like
smart yeah yeah I read you know books
Jerry
but I mean these people read like
they're reading like heavy dance yeah
information not an autobiography what
are you reading now Joe I'm reading uh
the gaudy Wars I think it's called about
Gotti getting taken down it has like
five books in circulation picks them up
and he reads a little bit next to the
bed I'm also reading uh Tarantino's
newest book and then the one about
Cinema and then cognitive behavioral
therapy I got to be working my uh brain
all the time I gotta kill myself and
what are you reading uh well I've had
Vanderpump Rules I'm waiting no I've I
there was one book I was I read Homo
sapiens and then I was like let me get
the second book and then I got homo
deuce and I've been uh reading that
slowly for about three years now okay
take your time you don't want a [__]
overload so you but you guys are
starting to get into the pattern that
you want to where you're both reading as
you go to bed I'll hit spurts I'm trying
but I can't I'll do Pinterest that's my
wind down activity out of the social
media likes the phone huh it's bad I'm
embarrassed Yeah by it I'm bad I mean I
don't want to make it sound like I mean
I just got this book and got fired up by
it but uh I'm bad I'm bad alone when I'm
with people I'm very good about the
phone or pretty good about the phone but
I'm on the road by myself though it's
awesome it's brutal dude I find myself
on an airplane like just going through
old pen or whatever like if I don't buy
the wife and just [__] look him yeah
just looking and I'm like what am I
doing I'll look at the guy's phone next
to me and then I know that I have work
to do that I could do and I'm just
refreshing yeah I'm like I should be
listening to set something I'm in the
plane for two hours I should be doing
something productive not trying to load
Instagram on a shitty Wi-Fi signal that
doesn't load it's bad is there ever a
vacation where just you guys if you
would you guys going other than the
honeymoon oh big time we went to Wales
we're going every year and then Sarah
wanted to have a [__] baby [__] this
whole planet but yeah we went to Paris
we went yeah you guys went to Berlin
last year they're really traveling we're
a big big truck I gotta travel I got I
go crazy I'm just gonna bring the baby I
can't uh that would be great for the
baby yeah yeah well culture yeah yeah
what do you do in Paris when what are
you eating over there we went to Paris
we spent a week I took Sarah for her
40th birthday she took me nowhere
um I have no money that was supposed to
be don't just be a laugh and nobody
laughed it got weird we actually did go
to Palm Springs we did okay on Joe on me
yeah in fact the other couple didn't
chip in either but um is that true I
think they forgot family they take care
of us yeah yeah but um
huge fans of yours by the way so they'll
hear this they're your parents but
um no let's keep it dabs what are we
doing it's a 700 house are you out of
your mind
eight [__] thousand here
Paris we walked a ton we went to the
Eiffel Tower we went to Notre Dame we
went to
um
yeah it was funny because I was like
we're in Europe we should have
cigarettes and Sarah just ripped like
two packs in about a half an hour it was
Wild start ripping heaters that's what
made me slip back going over there it's
romantic
I was at a wedding with Spaniards I was
like [__] they're a little bit better
for you over there too oh is that right
yeah it could be no no they're not
they're not if anything they're worse I
was like Griswold when he gives the kid
the beer and he looks over looks bad
it's gone I was like Jesus
uh we went to the Louvre and we went to
the parisy stuff what are you eating
over there croissants almost exclusively
we do like the ham and cheese croissant
are just straight regular croissants
yeah there you go I did cheese plotters
yeah what else do we pastries a lot of
pastries do fondue we do a little fondue
chicken fries I might have done a fondue
yeah I remember I don't remember what we
ate yeah it's a lot of pastries they're
an odd pair aren't they probably
McDonald's a little bit we do love a
McDonald's our honeymoon we ate in and
out burger every single day oh yeah yeah
if it's what you both like it's you know
that's it's your it's your week your
weekend whatever it is well you guys are
ordering fast food to the house no we
walk by a McDonald's I at least walk by
a McDonald's every night and I'm always
so proud of myself that I haven't
stopped by in there yeah because like I
feel like once you do then it's easier
the next time and the next time but I
love McDonald's every now and then yeah
it's the best it's the best I did get it
delivered to the house the day I got
back from La yeah so I have before oh
it's so good yeah the delivery is not
great though that's the best yeah it is
pretty good yeah because when I was
living on 35th Street in Astoria I'd
walk by that Burger King Astoria
Boulevard every night and I would stop
at the at the drive-through window it
was when they were doing like 10 burgers
a dollar so we're like give me give me
20. yeah yeah that's pretty fun we
picked up two uh Beefcake gay men and
drove them through the drive through one
time years ago late at night because
they didn't have their charity they
didn't have a car and they were like
real like beefy beef like 240 pound like
bodybuilder looking guys with like the
the string tanked up like down to here
and they were in line and I got a little
annoyed they were like on foot and then
they sent it like you can't do that you
get it's dangerous whatever and I said
uh hop in boys and I took them to the
drive-through and we ordered food and
then they didn't give me a proper thank
you really yeah they would have picked
up the dads they offered to buy anything
no and even though
like Garrett and I was like I thought
they should have been blowing me that's
why I don't help anybody anymore just
now one time those two gay guys at
Burger King never again Sarah's a big
believer in not helping I am you just
get caught in their drama and then they
want you to help more I don't disagree
with you yeah so I stopped helping
people happiness Sarah if you ask for
help I will if it's within reason but I
I just feel like it's messy
yeah it doesn't always end well my thing
uh well I want to get back to what we've
been talking about on the show is
speaking of the the reimbursement for
the trip will you guys send venmo
requests to somebody if they owe you
money no like say if it's been discussed
okay if they were like hey I just shared
a lift with a girl that I had just met
that night and we were both going back
to Astoria and she's like send me the
request after because I got out first
even though it was my account okay so I
requested her yeah
but no it feels awesome it's tacky she
did immediately yeah it comes off as
tacky I feel yeah unless it's set up the
way you're talking yes
yeah no I'm bad with it I've had people
buy I sell shirts on the road people be
like oh I got uh
twelve dollars and I'm like all right
you're losing money yeah it's costing me
13 bucks yeah no I've never venmo
requested it but I'm not I'm paying more
than I'm owed I feel like on venmo yeah
sure yeah most of all yeah people [__]
on couples that venmo each other back
but sometimes I just feel really bad
that Joe takes do you guys do that I
venmo him but I don't I don't know
I'm gonna need to see some proof let me
see a transaction you guys keep
everything I'm gonna ask you but do you
guys keep everything separate like just
Joe has his account and you have your
account yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not
getting any of my money I did the same
thing me and my wife didn't do it and
then she had we had a renew her green
card and they were like yeah yeah you
should have you should like have a
mortgage and all and we didn't unite
anything and they were like yeah you
have no actual paperwork no assets as a
couple nothing yeah well my car is under
your name because I don't have any
credit you didn't have good credit my
license was out of state yeah
so we put it online and I bought my car
making strong purchases on a Corolla
yeah Sarah goes in with a fake mustache
hi I'm Joe Lisk I'm here to buy a car it
was awkward because everything's in her
name but I I bought it so I don't know
it's gonna be ugly when we get divorced
are you guys both on the lease
no I don't think our landlord knows you
live there I don't know
I'm on because you're living like this
over here shoebox is a cash and
passports I haven't looked at the lease
since 88 our landlord's the best but he
didn't even do a background check on us
yeah he would have never got it he's uh
he's just that's old school Queen [__]
like real neighborhood [__] old school
Greek guys that you got yeah yeah
handshake deal or something yeah he's
great he's the best and um but everybody
always told oh my God it's so hard to
find like dude go to a store yet you'll
do it you got to dig around a little bit
and look a little bit you will find some
old couple that had a house that turned
it into three apartments that they live
on the top floor of the ground floor and
they're just looking for nice people to
live there they don't give a [__] well
that's what I forget because our
landlord is so nice and he he is so
accommodating and he lets us bring in
anybody we I just say hey Caitlyn palufo
and Steve Rogers and he goes great but I
think I forget that it's as hard to find
good tips
I mean they might go months without
having people in there and they're like
there's x amount of thousands and the
fact that you know them not like you're
on the hook for it but it's like you
know well Joe knows them you know
they're more than likely not to [__]
skip out on their rent or anything like
that would be embarrassing for us yes
right yeah yeah and we don't drink we
don't party we don't smoke I smoke in
the backyard a couple of stogies in the
backyard yeah never hurt no one honest
man Long Day's Work comes out as a cigar
you got that right
you guys should come up you guys smoke
smoke cigs I started smoking cigars uh
at Cassidy's wedding
I was always kind of anti-itch I didn't
feel like I I deserved it and say that
in a weird way and then I had one at his
wedding I wasn't crazy about it no you
complained about it the whole he was
smoking this [__] sucks how could
anyone ever do this later on that night
you know what let me get another one of
those yeah it just took and then after
that I had like one a couple weeks later
and then I had one at the World Series
and I was at a perfect amount of drinks
in me it was it was um uh Macanudo oh
yeah yeah it was in like macanoodle Cafe
and it was real nice and then since then
I've had a couple every once in a while
our buddy Hank and uh in uh Austin uh
shout out to Hank gave us gave me a
little bag of cigars to take back and
I've I've had a few of them all right
you gotta come over yeah they're all
right yeah it is relaxing very relaxing
it takes an hour to smoke a cigar so
every now and then there'll be somebody
that's like you want to smoke a cigar
and you're like we want to get home yeah
yeah so it feels weird to wrap this up
you're like I'm not saying no because I
don't want to smoke with you I just
don't want to hang out an hour at 11
o'clock at night sure yeah sure I gotta
watch Vanderpump Rules
uh but let's do some uh let's do some
garbage questions from the old uh
patreon over there okay uh gang when you
sign up for patreon answer your garbage
question on the air it's just the best
way to do it
uh let's see this one's from Jason ten
dollar homie have you ever owned one of
those touch lamps
that you can like oh oh I think I have
them in the closet that's different
that's a popper yeah
Family Feud yes like the buzzer looking
yeah those are tap lights with the
batteries yes we're talking about at a
certain point in I think late 90s
technology yeah you got rid of the Twist
on the lamp and you just touched the
thing it was like heat set and it goes
up and there would be like three
different levels to it no I never had
that never ever we know we're getting
you for the baby a couple of those
I remember my stepmom moved in she
pushed she made all of the lamps in the
living room that what's the appeal
people that's sleeker I think it's yeah
but easier just a little the hotel's had
them for a while yeah
yeah I don't sometimes you touch them
too hard and you go too fast yes can I
say that it's on the line with The
Clapper to me I don't I don't trust the
hotel USB in the wall never works also
what's the deal with loose sockets yes
iPhone charger in there and then they're
just like yeah slips out
bloody
[Laughter]
dirty little [__] yeah that's what I
always think when I'm like oh you dirty
[__] somebody was plowing this Outlet
in the bathroom and clean yourself up
well I mean yeah I don't like that do
you have a hotel that you'll stay at do
you have like one that you try to stay
at or you just wherever they throw you
up whatever's close to the club
um usually it's yeah usually it's
whatever the club puts me yeah we don't
I hear about Comics changing rooms A
million times oh and when you get it so
fascinated by whatever people I
understand every now and then you get an
outlier situation disgusting but like
you know I I think we usually just stay
where whatever we get yeah most clubs
now put you in a decent a decent yeah or
at least yeah we're doing I opened up
you're doing well enough where they're
not putting it they do because they do
have ranks of like these are for These
Guys these are these guys and these are
for these yeah yeah I opened up for
somebody years ago and that was like my
first foray into that right very classy
gentleman yeah and uh he's they put him
next to the uh elevator and he went
right downstairs like I can't to the
elevator I'm like I don't even know you
could [__] do that yeah but they
charge you or something yeah no I'm not
a real assertive with the hotel I go ah
that sucks yeah I had to do it once I
can't remember where we were but it was
basically a murder room yeah it was like
literally it was there was Pittsburgh
yeah there was huge burns on the carpet
it smelled like like there had been a
gang bang in there oh wow a few hours
before you're yeah you're like the Mojo
is awesome
I've done that once where I just felt
like the nun was in there yeah dude I
didn't like it that's the only time time
yeah I had to do it once in Houston I
walked in and it was like there was
people in here moments ago like I could
still feel it I'm like this is and there
was like a cold bottle of water like
half drank I'm like ah I can't do this
that's like No Country for Old Men
no still cold did you like that Joe I
did like that the movie I'm sorry I just
went off thinking about like the bad
hotels I've stayed in but No Country for
ones the top 10 for me I mean that's
like Alzheimer comedy condos hate them
awful and should be got get rid of them
Denver Comedy Works oh that's the best
Denver's good I just don't like that
it's Loft that you can still hear
because I'm a snorer and then people get
mad the ceilings there's no walls don't
go to the ceiling yeah but that's great
actually the uh air mattress in there is
from us we've well remember we bought
and left an air mattress there and we
stole the air mattress I think they
forgot to ring us up well we started
doing on the road because we travel with
a a gaggle of us we just started doing
airbnbs which is a little nicer and
sometimes cheaper than the
especially if you're taking an opener
with you I don't know you know what
whatever it makes the hangs better the
hang's better you got a nice living room
you're together you can make coffee and
[__] like that I'm not crazy about going
back to a hotel room by myself
on the one when we're out there I feel
in the back of my head this is anxiety
obviously but in the back of my head I'm
like they're gonna find me in here
tomorrow morning
yeah which okay yeah we've all matted in
the front of it in front of a hotel me
like anybody got eyes on the big man
yeah and we're like no we're calling
texting everything it'll be me and Toby
learning each other like
all right man let's [__] yeah they're
trying to piece together the night what
happens
at 7-Eleven it looks like I just I did
I've used Matt Wayne a lot on the road
who's great you guys know Matt yeah yeah
yeah wonderful but he uh we did Denver
Comedy Works together we had the condo
that was fun and then Tampa Side
Splitters has a new condo and it's not
the nicest but the hotel isn't great and
it's further away so I was like I'll
just stay at the shop it's quite fun to
have a roommate
that's what we love about the airport
yeah
it's the best it is oh we were there
right after you I think oh we got the
pooch
you can't walk in the grass everyone's
laughing no one's ever tried to lay in
grass in Tampa it's 150 degrees and
you've got a lot of real dum-dums
everywhere though I know that's a
special bro I mean Tampa it's like Tampa
dum dum I'm a Kentucky
grass I know what I know what kind of
gray it's off it's crazy
it's like a cat tongue on one side yes
Texas has the same grass but Tampa it's
it's more it's affordable you went to St
Augustine grass I think
and it's very it's very flat down there
the ballpark is horseshit the Bucks logo
is gay are you you're a big beach guy
though I like the beach I like to become
a race you couldn't be going to raise
games oh it's a trash Heap that place no
offense I mean it was a little Trash
Tampa for eight minutes wow but I love
Tampa's fantastic he's a [__] Red Sox
fan he can't they're in the same goddamn
Division I know but I I like Tampa
because Tampa is a lot of Northeast
people that's like the lineage is it's a
very close extension yes live up here
it's like a stepbrother yeah that's
right and uh and I love Side Splitters
and uh you know big bride's the best
yeah Norman's uh batch is probably we
did in Tampa right yeah yeah right right
right if you run into somebody down
there like say somebody uh like if
you're picking up a shirt or something
like that to happen to me I went to the
big and tall in Tampa and when we got
down there pick up a couple of guys
Rider a couple items and the guy in
there he's like where are you coming in
from coming from New York oh where do
you live in New York I live in I live in
a story oh yeah another story I lived up
there yeah yeah it's that that feeling
yeah it's like an extension of the city
and the best cigar prices in the country
very low yeah my backup plan is to move
to Tampa and be a power washer
or stuff that's Tick Tock time yeah yeah
I just yeah that's or car detailing yeah
that's big do you know there's a video
game that's all Lawns and abandoned
houses your job is that guy's great
guy's pretty good yeah the whole the
whole video game is your job is you own
a small power washing company and you
got like jobs oh yeah Danny Brown and
you see results right away oh it's the
instant gratification you know what else
is there another one that's been killing
me lately the carpet cleaning guys oh I
love that they clean the uh
it's called the oranges
uh like do you mean like the rugs yes
and they're just chancellors at the
forefronto
I don't even know what you're talking
about lost over here there it's like a
it's like a rug cleaning company and
they they restore rugs they get like a
rug like a oriental rug a nice oriental
rug that was like just trash a body was
buried in it yeah and they'll put it on
this like it looks like a baby pool and
they'll just hit it with this and that
and power wash and then they take like
uh like a like a like a sucker yeah Mr
thirsty they throw it away dude it's
nice I'm always like they're doing like
40 hours of work for something that'll
give them a 10 profit it feels like yeah
it's a lot yeah I think if they're
expensive rugs they probably do pretty
well wouldn't you think so maybe yeah
I've always wondered yeah
[__] Rug Doctor over there I'm Blown
Away by that like Joseph you're getting
french fries or pizza what are you
talking about that's right and if I
spill it on the rug I clean it myself I
don't watch a guy you're watching carpet
cleaners
what's the world coming to it's
satisfying it's perverse
uh all right let's do a couple more it's
always a good app when you barely get to
the goddamn question yeah we love you
too uh well uh this is from Devin will
either one of you wear shoes to the
beach
what do you mean I wear sneakers on the
beach really black socks and sneakers
I don't like doing it I like I
flip-flops so I can wash my feet as much
as I can with my shoe on
wait meaning like you can rinse your
feet
you can't do that with the snake you're
doing New Balances on the beach that's
right how you going in the water well I
take them off to go in the water but
then you gotta wait
then you're going back to the chairs
with your wet Sandy feet putting socks
on it's bad well you put them back on on
the beach before I leave I put it back
on no wait a minute it's all sandy
here's the big question
don't get out of here and I also there's
something about a flip-flop a man hoof
is disgusting I can't wear a flip-flop
it's and this is just me being from the
80s this guy's cool balls dude hold on
here's the craziest part of it is it the
only pair of sneakers you have with you
yeah yeah that yeah you have sand in
your sneakers for the rest of the time
you're at wherever you are clap it out I
don't know you're crazy I don't say the
first few years of dating Joe he was
kind of into water socks like water
shoes yeah well in Maine I still wear
them because it's rocking it's Rocky
socks yeah and you walk into the beach
they call it water shoes there's no
Beach in Maine it's rocks yeah
I got City feet
I'm not I'm not
Barefoot I'm not a they're tender yeah
they're very soft they're delicate sure
and then I'm walking on rocks I mean if
you've never been to New England
sharp and slippery yeah there's bricks
and [__] in there yeah yeah I'll give
you that huh I'll give you that much of
those my dad used to wear Aqua Socks
like a rant like he wore them his shoes
he'd wear them like the grocery store
yeah it was crazy I saw him and it's
[__] everyone like a ninja I saw him
at a shop right one time and [__]
walk the other way couldn't do it huh
all right uh have you ever this is from
Thomas have you ever taken a bath towel
or shower towel to the beach instead of
a beach towel from hotels yes
hotel and maybe even a comedy condo it
sucks and I don't know why it sucks it's
not as thick it's smaller it's thinner
it's rougher yeah yeah it's not a beach
towel and even sometimes if the hotel
has a pool and their pool towels they're
basically just regular towels with
stripes on them yeah you're not fooling
anybody I love you know what I want if I
was rich
beach towels in my bathroom look at you
every time I go back to my mom like back
they're luxurious that's what I use in
the shower I mean I think we can afford
that I wish I had 13.99
if I ever can afford to go to a Macy's I
mean I got an equinox membership for
God's sakes we're in the Delta Lounge
we're doing all right and do you guys
have uh a matching set of towels at the
house like is there if I walked into
your bathroom is there like the little
bar with the two hand towels and the
washcloth over it no turquoise she's
turquoise I'm Brown Yeah that's the
that's a we were given them by his
family and then I've never I was like
well now we're good we don't need towels
for another 20 years yeah when we get
the house when we buy a house we'll
probably have some letters do all that
stuff whatever some Monograms yeah my
roommate got me really nice towels but
they got dingy pretty fast
now there's a guest house okay Joe comes
on all the time every towel you got I
guess are you really coming on the
bathtub no well at a hotel sure but
that's like guys don't know hierarchy of
towels in the religions I've learned
since I've been married where you're
like that's the teacher
well like you just dry your hands off
the tea towel hand towel hand towel yeah
yeah but then I've seen guys to kill
like swipe up like Kool-Aid messes with
it where you're like oh my God they're
great I'll I'll flip it over so my
girlfriend's not doing but I'll give the
sink a once over with the hands
now how do you guys feel about this I go
to I go to the gym I'm at the steam room
you wear the towel in the steam room
every once in a while the steam gets the
nose dripping at least I blow my nose
into the towel I'm wearing how do you
feel about in front of people or Bob
will you be by yourself by myself
possibly to someone there and I'll throw
it out there so there's just a green
snow gun that yeah it's not great it's
not great but you have to when you're
using those you operate under the
assumption until he's throwing up
dude what what well you guys the nose is
running I'm
not your nose but to like [__] to
really get some get a motor behind that
all right yeah I would say it's okay and
I'm pretty I'm I'm pretty that's this
isn't a guy you want on your side when
it comes to hygiene I'm pretty nasty
when it comes to in the hotel with the
towels and the bedroom and the and the
bed I'll
not blow my nose in the sheets on the
bed but I will if I sneeze I'll wait my
my nose with it oh gotcha I gotcha yeah
I know what you mean and also to see one
on your side is the mountain you wanted
the hell you want to die on Joe I don't
know about that I'll blow my nose and
stuff but also if I have if I happen to
be in the in the hotel bed alone and
I ejaculate yeah that's staying there
on the comforter because they don't
clean those as often well they should
they should that's their mistake yeah
imagine going into a hotel room after
you that's how somebody walks in because
this don't feel right
but I literally just did it you guys
were in Columbus I came the next time we
had an Airbnb thank Christown Christmas
which we didn't get the we didn't get
the deposit back for it no kidding I'm
kidding that's why I have a tide stick
next to our bed all right that'll kill
him clean the [__] Stains yeah really
[__] I don't travel every day Martha
stored over here well there's leakage
when there's leakage Oh you mean it at
the house can I say this the tide stain
stick and the Mr Clean Magic Eraser
might be two of the greatest products
the magic erasers they both actually
[__] work yeah incredibly I spilled a
whole hot dog on my jeans what and I
managed to do my laundry while we were
in Chicago and I was so amazed how much
it got out of my pants yeah yeah the
tide stain stuff yeah but I was
basically just doing laundry in the
stadium yeah in the stadium while we
were watching the baseball game uh oh at
Wrigley yeah wait where I was doing
laundry I think in the bathroom okay
that's so big I thought you're right
into the laundry matter using the team's
facility so what are you guys doing the
towels around here Sarah's in the
clubhouse I get these jock straps out of
here I gotta do the load real quick
how'd you get in here anyway
all right we gotta wrap it up guys yeah
time blew by baby congratulations you're
two of our absolute favorites thank you
everybody loves you we can't thank you
enough for coming in where am I on the
all-time appearances am I second third
time wise like a number of times uh yeah
you're up there right there this is
probably what five
it's at least four at least five and
this is Sarah's your third or fourth my
third third yeah I think I think Joe's
at five and you're at three yeah yeah
all right we love you yeah I don't think
anybody beats five
um what do you guys got coming up here
please
um okay uh Irvine Improv July 13th
through the 15th and then San Jose
Improv July 20th through the 22nd those
are places I'm going to be
and uh I got a new special coming on
August 18th there you go YouTube yeah so
go subscribe to my YouTube check out the
previous one this year's material
killing it seen it already and I got
another one called I hate myself so you
got two hours to watch before the new
hour and uh yeah my YouTube subscribe
there one of the best one of the
funniest thank you Sarah I'm in Columbus
Ohio July 14th and 15th for the don't
tell I don't know exactly where that is
but it's Columbus and it's on my website
Columbus go check her out of course two
of the absolute best we love you both
Kippy what do you got for him uh we're
all over the road we just announced and
just announced 20 new cities so get
those tickets uh
those are gonna sell out hopefully
several of them of the venues are way
too big so buy those tickets early bring
the squad and tell your whole goddamn
family all right gang we love you gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace